when we talk about conmen from the past
normally
they're met with disdain disgust there's
a sense that
all these people need to be put behind
bars
but every now and then a scammer comes
along who really
captures the imagination who shows us
the foolishness
of our biases and how easy it is to
trick us and it almost
delights us in a weird way one such
example is frank abagnale he was the
guy featured in catch me if you can the
movie and the whole idea
is that he spent his life sort of faking
being an
airline pilot an attorney a doctor
but he did it in such a way that seemed
perhaps to not be for money but for the
sheer
thrill of getting away with it and
because of that he's become something
of an icon and even has moved on from
his scammer ways
into something more respectable and that
latter type of scammer is what i'm
interested in
today because the person we're talking
about today is
a scammer yes but he also when i review
his files
i can't help but find myself fascinated
by this person
fascinated by the doctor of love but the
teen later told police
he'd never attended medical school i
don't appreciate
your tone if you could stop recording
please i will lie like that
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffee zilla and today
we're talking about the man myth
the legend the doctor of love himself
malachi love robinson dodge that
this is him right here guys you may have
you may know him you may not
but he was featured on the local news a
while back as a young
con man let's take a listen an alleged
fraud of such
audacity such tenacity that it boggles
the mind
it involves an 18 year old babyface kid
who's accused of masquerading as a
doctor police say treating patients
out of his own clinic that's right dr
malachi
love robinson or dr love as we'll be
calling him throughout the rest of this
piece
was a 19 year old kid who faked being a
doctor and set up a private practice
and was treating patients he has a lab
coat and a stethoscope
but police say this baby-faced physician
doesn't have an md are you a fraud
because it seems like everything you're
saying to me is invasive
i don't appreciate your tone gosh i love
that you get caught and you go i don't
appreciate your tone
actually i don't like when you say that
but let's
set the stage okay let's back it up
before we get into
the heated confrontation dr love didn't
start by being confronted on being a
doctor he actually had
practice he had dreams of being a doctor
for a fake doctor dreams of being a fake
doctor for a long time
ever since he was 17 he sort of roamed
the halls it sounds like
of various medical places pretending
and just sort of like walking around
with a lab coat on the police report
says he was walking around the halls
in a doctor's code i believe it said
department of anesthesiology on it
witnesses reporting he'd been roaming
the hospital halls for a month
dude how does anybody mistake this guy
for a doctor
i like the serious expression though
dude this guy's committed to the
character
this story was broadcast everywhere like
i'm some
insane maniac
nobody else is faking being being a
doctor at least we can say you're a one
of one that's one thing you'll notice
actually about malachi
is that he has a tremendous amount of
confidence that belies his young teenage
years and that's something that i find
fascinating i think most people find
fascinating about scammers
is they typically have an above average
ability to bs their way through
situations that they have
no idea about i'm sure malachi has never
been on the local news before
or definitely not the national news
before but he bses his way through it
like a pro
didn't snatch out a baby i didn't do any
of that police
snapped this picture of the lab coat in
his car on one lapel the title
anesthesiologist
on the other his name oh that's a bad
luck bud that's where you get in trouble
i think probably if he had walked
through with just a lab coat he probably
wouldn't have gotten in trouble but
now that you fake your credentials
that's the problem hospital did not
press charges claiming in a statement
the individual never had contact with
any hospital patients
and did not gain access to any patient
care areas
now by the way i'll be skipping through
this because there's a full report on
this
great investigative reporting by abc
news you can go check it out it's called
florida teen accused of posing as a
doctor denies diagnosing patients
i want to skip to the part where they
actually go into his clinic where he was
his private practice and show you what
he was doing this
this kid is unbelievable attempting to
pass as a medical doctor
this time in his very own clinic this is
the new birthing life medical
center so he doesn't know that this girl
walking with him
like is an undercover reporter labor law
posters up on the wall
so that way you know they are visible to
the public all right this is
dude what oh my gosh he goes hey look
labor laws that means i'm legit so that
way you know they are visible to the
public
and she goes you're following the law
and she knows that he's faking being a
doctor and he thinks he's getting away
with this that's unbelievable
all right of course that was after he
removed his lab coat and stethoscope
and when you peel back the tape the sign
on the door has his name
and those two crucial letters
no doctor love no you gotta learn bud
now this case gets more serious when we
learn of accusations
that dr love was not merely playing
doctor he was actually
acting as a doctor and treating patients
for money he was immediately confronted
on this
86 year old woman police say he treated
her recently for severe stomach pain
and charged her nearly 3 500 dollars
what services did you provide in
exchange for that money
i can tell you this accusations are
merely accusations
hey dude don't ever start a question
with another like a statement that has
nothing to do with the question i'm sure
that's how brian rose answers any kind
of questions
accusations are just accusations
and services you'd have to define that
um whether she paid for me to just show
up that's up to her
what this kid is unreal he's a legend
he never never defeated never defeated
at the bs game
he's saying i didn't even give her
services she paid me 3 500
to show up she was so happy to see my
face denying the fact
that she paid you 3 500 or so
correct no i am denying that are you a
fraud
i don't appreciate your tone i don't
appreciate
the way you're portraying this interview
to actually be and then a moment
we didn't expect i don't know where
you're seeing this information from but
it is
inaccurate um i'm sorry i'm gonna have
to cut this
in this interview short wow that is
unbelievable
look at that his outrage about getting
called out
truthfully dude he's 19.
the kid could be a hollywood star actor
star this is such a power play i don't i
don't even know what to think of this
i don't know where you're seeing this
information from but it is inaccurate
um i'm sorry i'm going to have to cut
this in this interview short
he has said this may not cut his medical
career short saying
he hopes to open another look at that he
hits him with this kid's a star dude
normally people would be walking out
with their head duck like low
this kid is going like you'll be hearing
from my lawyers dude
so here's the thing he goes to jail for
this now he gets talked to
in jail he served like a three-year
stint he really gave a compelling
message to inside addition here behind
that deception
as a kid you know i think it was always
been my dream
you know to be a physician i guess the
bigger picture was seeing the smiles you
know people thinking that you are
something that you're not
he sounds pretty compelling huh like he
he really is remorseful for what he did
and that he
really just deep down wanted to be a
doctor
all along well he got out recently
and um unfortunately ladies and
gentlemen he is once again
in the news dr love is re-arrested in
palm beach county
i regret to inform you guys in january
2020
according to the police under the name
alex robinson he got a job with the
united states of freight
a shipping brokerage based in delray
beach delray police say he stole more
than 10 thousand dollars from the
company
by diverting payments to the company
into his own bank account
now this is the problem with scammers of
all kind
because once you scam by pretending to
be a quack you can never go back
it's an old saying and this is
unfortunately the sad part of uh
of scamming is i think for for some
people it's just it's just a disease
they can't they can't help it they have
to
they're pathological liars but for me at
least dr
love represents one of the most
interesting figures
in scamming not because what i think he
did was right i think it's incredibly
dangerous to fake being a doctor but
because his motivations were so
different than your average
guru it wasn't to get a lambo it wasn't
to teach a bunch of 15 year olds how to
drop ship for him
it was about being seen like he was in a
position of authority
and he was helping you regardless of
whether he could actually help you or
not
and i think the fact that he's convinced
and tricked so many people
along the way is a testament to our
human fragility when it comes to trust
we're so quick to trust other people
if they have the right thing on if they
have the right coat on it's an old
saying that
if you put a construction outfit on you
carry a clipboard you can get into any
job site in the world and unfortunately
examples like this are reminders that we
need to be careful
and check our human biases and that
ladies and gentlemen is where our story
ends
with dr love robinson once again
committing another form of fraud
but going down in my heart as one of the
most lovable and hilarious scammers i
think when he gets out he should try
acting
anyway that's it thanks for watching see
you in the next one
wake up and smell the coffee